i see my thing flashing so i think it's
working
but i don't hear you i now you will hear
me
now i hear you it's my it was my fault i
was playing among us
oh and then you get into situations
where you can't talk
because you're not quite alive uh yeah i
haven't had to deal with that yet
it's going to happen eventually though
it's a good game
love it i was just kind of trying to
begin to explain to chats but we can
work things out
right now too we're going to play like a
themed
opening match right we can play
basically two games of each opening and
perhaps chat can
can pick out some of uh the more obscure
openings for us to
to dive into i agree let's do that
i know you had the one in mind of this
like actual
playable bond cloud line yeah in this
vienna which perhaps we can start with
yeah the famous steinette slime
yeah the king's gambit knight c3
and in fact this is i think the oldest
bomb cloud ever
things like 1900s queen h4 and king e2
and this been played by steinitz and won
a gazillion times
it was also played by kasparov against
karjakin
yeah karjakin and what's that that was i
think that was one of the st louis
events in
2017 probably st louis rapid and blitz
not that long ago actually
this is one of the choices okay yeah so
i i have not done any sort of
preparation so i would just go into this
uh kind of trying to figure things out
but uh
how about don't worry about it me
neither
okay sounds good okay
all right so we'll both be streaming uh
so people can watch
his stream as well and uh we're gonna
start
with this crazy crazy opening
it's really scary going into something
with no
nope not costume
okay um okay so
this is uh the first few moves i have to
play
queen h4 and then king e2
oh dear
i have no idea what to do here and it
looks like a nice position
the king's on e2 white's going to take
over the center soon
and d5 i think is thematic
maybe knight f6
knight c6 i want to play to get to
deform and then there's pawn d4
[Music]
oh boy if i play this there's this move
yeah let's um
how bad is this because i have this move
i do queen f2 and also i think i'll
start with this
but that knight f3 queen h6 e5
man i don't know what to do here d5
knight takes d5 and then maybe c6
okay i have an idea i'm gonna um i'm
gonna start with this
a knight f3 queen h5
and then i play this there's some
eventual idea of 93
this has to be like objectively better
for black i think
hey it's kimmy what's up kimmy shout out
to kimmy
yeah if you're just joining what what
did i just do
there we go um if you're just joining
uh we're doing an opening themed match
and i guess i sacrificed some time
i have g5 here and g5 is kind of cool
idea g4
yeah chesweem is he's kind of a
specialist in like weird
offbeat openings he's also very strong
in in rapid and blitz
so i'm going to have to be very very
careful
i'm tempted to play g4 here
the g4 f4 hangs
i could undevelop
or i could go for this plan
okay let's go for this i have to be very
very cognizant of time
this is actually a really cool line
i'm gonna have to take a look at that uh
that kasparov game
it's a bishop e7 i think makes sense um
because if the knight move ever moves
away i want to make sure i'm covering f6
i'm sure chess phoebe is dreaming of uh
getting this fork
and there's some idea of like d5 or f5
or maybe some combination of the moves
always have to watch out for ompassant
though
ooh so this pawn is pinned for the time
being
i guess the threat is just to take
so maybe h6
and yeah there is increments so if i got
really long time i can still survive
but ideally i don't want to get
too too down on the clock
now let's go for this
man this is just such a mess
okay d5 in positions like this you just
want to make
your pieces as happy as possible so
bishop or pawn can come in
in this pawn
the king on e2 is so awkward it wants to
run away but then there's
there's some idea of knight f2
i wouldn't be able to play knife two
immediately
but here i could kick the knight and
then go for this
interesting
hmm
i'm just blocking the e-file preparing
this
eric i'm trying
but which bank oh the blood bank oh
i haven't been inside a bank in a long
time
i just like to use a mobile app
does the blood bank have like a mobile
app
i think i'm winning material though like
the king has found kind of some refuge
but
the knights attacked and the light moves
i triple fork
oh the counter attack
wait what so if i take take
oh it's getting messy i think it's okay
for me
i have rook c8 there's bishop e5
man this is a mess my rook's defended by
the bishop
oh dear i could castle
castle like a boss
i have no idea what's going on here
let's just take a knight
problem with castling i had to keep the
bishop defended wow what does this move
let's take here threaten double check
maybe
oh no
how bad is this
oh tricky move so if takes i check and
win
oh
what is this position wow am i winning
might be winning i have so many pawns
look at my pawns
look at this it's so beautiful
kind of wait oh he's getting a queen too
though
no i have so many pawns
no there goes all my pawns
wow that was so crazy good game
this was probably a bad move yeah that
was a bad move
i was so excited about my pawns though
but i guess
the rook and bishop they were too too
solid this pawn was annoying
gg because i i think that was so rich
in tactical ideas and combinations that
i think it would be
miss if you don't look at it definitely
uh i just brought it in
wait is this the right game this is yeah
right
yeah yes this was insane
and i think knight f6 is somewhat
inaccurate because you never can't go
back
anymore i just didn't know like it's so
hard to
i just i can't remember last time i've
been in like such an early theoretical
position having no prior knowledge
yeah so go ahead
so i just i it was so hard to come up
with a move here because i i had all
these ideas of like maybe d5
or like at some point knight c6 i mean i
had some sense of like what my resources
should be yeah
but it's so hard to actually calculate
thoroughly
yeah i mean i think you sort of
mix the two lines so it's not really uh
like a normal king's gambit you have to
go indeed
with this d5 wave like go very aggro
actually maybe knight c6 first so event
time
and then you will have d5 but as you're
asking i'm losing sight about how do you
do that
yeah no i i see i took a quick peek at
the database so d5 is the most popular
move yeah so some
d5 here and some like bishop d6 here
knight c6 bishop g4 castles
this is the main main line and it does
get crazy because
i can go some lacking d3 the king being
useful in the center
and what's fascinating about this whole
thing
that it's not like it's terrible for
white
black has to be very accurate to show
that
this is bad gotcha
faski won this like against the grand
master like four months
our post coach he killed him in this
time
no this would be a fascinating line to
like kind of look up the the famous
games in
especially among like top players yeah
the reason
so the reason i didn't play d5 in like
immediately
i just thought it did more help for you
than harm
where like it just gives you more talk
like that i thought the knight's just
better on g5 anyway
i guess like i didn't realize the power
of getting the bishop in
and then maybe use your knight later on
as a target
it's more of like you're getting quick
development
so i think you're completely right that
the knight is nice on d5
but you're just rushing in to get pieces
which makes sense yeah i mean i guess
it's a very thematic idea for this
opening especially
with the king on e2 yeah so i mean
knight f6 is logical
but i think this g5 idea just doesn't
belong in this system
here queen h5 and i'm actually very
mad at myself for knight e4 because i
think knight d5 is just
so much better oh yeah i was kind of
scared of this because this pawn is a
yeah a bit vulnerable you can even go
some like king e1 instead of this threat
i might have c6 here but it's it's
uncomfortable yeah it's very
uncomfortable so knight e4 i think was
inaccurate
i was happy to get the bishop uh yeah to
restrict
the show one nice little trick here
d5 i have h hg takes a night after
trapping the queen oh
actually that wasn't i was just too
tempted for this one
uh-huh pretty i don't know if you
uh looked at this at all i i did not see
that i just assumed that the pin is
always working
mm-hmm um wait
so what happened in the game then
because you had seven
i didn't have don't have this trick
because oh i have a h6 square ah
okay yeah i i was not aware of that idea
at all
yeah it's kind of cool yeah
h4 h6 here knight c6
here takes and probably i should have
played thief
for sure because once i allowed five
i think you were yeah i know the
position was so comfy for me
yeah and then i mean i was so happy
even like late okay things were just a
big mess
yeah i was curious if i had any chances
like with my pawns rolling on the king's
side
yeah towards the end
i mean this is just very good we were
both like
we were both in severe time trouble like
six seconds to 11 seconds
yeah um i didn't even see e7 was hanging
with check
but i think maybe that was a good
practical try
yeah like i wasn't getting made it i was
fighting to queen your king was a target
and then i just tried to you
is that rook takes c6 um
knight e3 queen how about their screen
f6
so you're stuck here that's the problem
yeah i was proud of this idea rookie 8
like yeah that was very nice but
actually maybe wait wait wait
maybe you have knight e3 queen e2 so
instead of rookie
no i still have you still have queen f6
right
it's such a hard breaker honestly
i didn't i didn't say you could play
queen e2 here but thankfully i had f3
yeah and just such a and so many plot
twists
f3 knight e4 and i mean that bishop e3
is a must
otherwise i'm pretty pretty sure i'm
lost that's crazy like i'm down
two whole rooks basically yeah and i
have only one move yeah
like these pawns are so magnificent yeah
i guess the thing is that here you
shouldn't have taken the rook
yeah i got carrick i got i got too
excited i just saw my pawn rolling down
and
i forgot you have a pawn too yeah so
maybe it's not like queen g4
yeah queen g4 and then this is a threat
and your bishop and rook are still tied
down
um can i go back and take
but that must be lost because i'll
probably just get my pawn to each shoe
and chill like maybe
keep i have literally five pawns
in and three different files so i'll
probably run all of them
when do you ever have five fawns on one
side
you know what i could do if you just do
nothing like because you're kind of
stuck anyway
yeah obviously you wouldn't do this but
something like this
and then takes takes and i have a
massive like pawn
it's almost a pawn rectangle but you can
go
f2 yeah you bet you can't bring this guy
over to
f3 and this is good
even if like you tried you know it would
be so nice
yeah anyway that was a great game